foreign
[Music]
hey everyone this is my cousin's sister
Sam she's from L.A staying with me now
nice to meet you I'm Melissa captain of
the price team let's take it from the
top Break Every Chain
she writes songs the chorus is the
strongest product if we lose the rest
and type the Loose Ends it could be
really special lose the rest
every team has their Lane and our lane
is real church music how about you learn
an actual gospel song first
is the only thing Atlanta has gone for
it okay about to go up in there about to
meet him it's about to be great I would
like to thank my cousin Jess for being
my ride or die in Atlanta when my dad
forced me to go out there and I didn't
want to go out there it's family
business we outside oh God he sees us
don't worry about me your voice is nice
why don't you come down to the studio
you should sing this song at that church
thing
[Music]
I changed the music what it's gonna be
great we are terrified I don't really
have a relationship with God God use
fish donkeys even hoes to get his word
across what's going on I think she just
called me huh oh I like this twerking
for the Lord we do not think you're
going straight to hell as some people
have said oh Church Girl Gotta put him
out there
[Applause]
so y'all really think God's gonna waste
a miracle on y'all this year huh shall I
heard that clap back all the way over
here let's get our praise on
it three songs hit people's heart a
little different Hands-On
[Applause]
[Music]
radical Pros
can I get an amen
[Music]